okay so i'm really going uh
for elementary here so it's going to be
uh
two stories or if you want the story in
two parts
uh
whether it's going to be a comedy or a
tragedy that's uh
sort of up to the audience okay so i'm
going to talk about sort of really very
elementary results so
and because they're so elementary
they're even going to apply in a
slightly more general setting so i will
not really talk about tensor rank but i
will talk about
rank with respect to variety so
our setup is going to be like this so we
will have a projective variety
uh inside pn
and uh
well with the sound field but our field
is going to be
only reals or complex for the stock we
won't really care about other
possibilities okay so now let me define
x rank
of a point
in c or k n plus one
so
in order to do this so let me use okay
so i have a projective variety but in
fact you know so projective variety
lives in the projective space so i will
take the cone over projective variety
that's going to live in the actual
vector space so x hat is
cone over x so
these are so what is what does this mean
this means these are all
p in
jn plus 1
such that
the class of p
is an x
so maybe let me draw a picture so we
have a cone
yeah i think this is the uh this is the
canonical picture of a cone if you ask
somebody to draw a cone this is what
they will draw
this is perhaps
limitation of drawing okay
so now
we have a point so what is the x rank of
p
well so i decompose this is equal this
is equal to the minimum
number
k such that i write p
as the sum of x i from i equals 1 to k
and x i
live in the cone over x
okay so i have a cone i have a point
somewhere in the space and then i want
to decompose it in the minimal possible
way as the sum of the elements of the
cone
okay and uh so
what boot is this so this is essentially
i mean this definition for different
varieties x
encompasses
all reasonable notions of dead sarang so
examples
when x is the segreg or
the image of the segger embedding of
pian this corresponds to
tensor rank
when x is the varanasi
this corresponds to symmetric tensor
rank
and uh you know when x is the grasmanian
this corresponds to anti-symmetric
answering
okay
so
so we're going to work the even more
generality so not just for tenses we're
going to talk about the rank with
respect to
any variety
uh so before right so
then the question is well can we say
anything useful in this generality right
can we say anything useful in this
generality so before i proceed uh are
there any questions about the setup
because this is this is the notion that
i will work with so
we better understand what's going on
are there any questions
everything clear okay
so right so then part one
is uh joint work with zidak titler
and what we're going to address is the
question of maximum rank
okay so what can we say about the
maximum rank
of uh of a point with respect to variety
well you can say something sort of uh
immediately obvious thing that you can
say is that
max rank is at most
n plus one because that's the dimension
of the ambient extra space so actually
let me just say so i mean i need to in
order to define x rank i better assume
that x is
not degenerate
uh and nondegenerate just means that it
actually spans the whole space or if you
want the cone spans the ambient vector
space if it doesn't spin then you know i
cannot really define the rank for every
point
right some points will be just outside
the span and uh
i will also assume that x is irreducible
uh i mean for i think for many things
this might not be necessary but for all
of these examples in any case it's the
case so i would say for all relevant
more most anything exactly happen to be
reducible anyway so we might as well
assume it
no loss okay so max rank is at most n
plus one i think that should be clear
because well just by linear algebra so
can we say something better so
over c
so let's do so for part 1.1 let's work
over c or
over probably any algebraic a closed
field of characteristic zero but let's
stick to c
right so over c can we say something
better so in fact we can say that the
max rank
is at most n plus one
minus dimension x and this observation
was made by
believe garameta and also by landsberg
titler this is
very easy to
understand that you can
get away with a little bit better
than just the trivial bond then plus one
which basically works all the time
doesn't matter what field and so on
okay
so but uh but can we do can we do better
than this in the general circumstances
so
over an algebraically closed field
tensor well now our algebraic
closed field now we forget about tensors
but there is a generic x rank so over c
there is
a generic x rank
and so what this means is that
tensors of generic rank
form a dense open subset of c n plus one
and in fact you know the the study of
what is the generic rank this is uh
well this that is a very sort of well
established area perhaps the most uh
the most famous
result
is the alexander hershevitz theorem
and essentially it gives the uh
well one way to say it
this tells you the generic rank
generic symmetric rank
and
uh i mean there also there are also many
results
uh many results on the generic
non-symmetric rank although not uh not a
full classification as given by
alexander hershevitz
and there is i mean well yeah so this
has been essentially finding the generic
rank is
almost the same as
figuring out
dimensions
of
secant varieties
2x and this is usually done like in the
previous talk we're using the terracini
llama although i mean that's just the
first step right the story doesn't end
there but you need but usually you need
to use the territory lemma to get down
to uh actually figuring out what's going
on
okay but for me you know in a sense
uh
i don't really i well i don't i'm not
going to use this point of view all that
i need to know is that there is a
generic x rank right that's that's what
i need to know
so what can we say now about the maximal
rank
and the generic rank so this will bring
us to let's say theorem one
maximal
x rank
is at most
twice the generic x-ray
and i'm going to prove this later but
i'm actually i'm going to state more
theorems before i do that and then i
will prove more than one theorem with
the same proof is this sharp
um no
i mean how should i put it the i would i
would say well okay
let me hold off so after i give the
proof i will make some general remarks
one oh yeah and then you will you will
see what's going on okay it depends what
you mean by sharp there you go
there's this example well
x where you do get twice
yeah okay yeah but uh but in general
this will not really be okay
yeah let me this is the last title
so yeah yeah that's yeah that's right so
let
let's just hold off and wait for 10
minutes and i hope you will be more
satisfied
later
okay
um
so this is right so this is what happens
over c
so
now what can we say over r so actually
over r
the situation is a little bit different
or depending on your perspective may be
a lot different because there is no
longer a unique generic rank in fact
over r there are several ranks
for which tensors of this rank
contain an open set
or open subset of rn plus one so
now let's think about over r so here x
is going to be
a real variety
and by that i really mean that x better
have dense real points right i don't
want to think about
you know varieties that are given by
real equations but somehow they don't
contain as many real solutions as
complex solutions right so real variety
so variety with dense real points
so yeah so what can happen well so
imagine this is our space rn plus one
then it happens
that perhaps here is an open ball and
these these guys have rank three and
here is an open ball these guys have
rank four
so there are several there
often happens that there are several
ranks such that tensors of such iran
contain an open ball and site strengths
are called typical
so let me use sr
this is the set of tensor not tensors
vectors this is there are no tensors
everything vectors of rank
r
and then the definition
so rank
r is called typical
if sr
contains
an open ball
and rn plus one and open ball i mean in
the usual euclidean topology on rn plus
one does this renko mean that there's an
arcade in a other piece expression
preserved by complex conjugation or that
the sum of our real things
that's right so this yeah so when i say
yeah so real rank it means that all of
these salmons are real so it's not
conjugate invariant one but really one
consisting of real real underlying
vectors
okay
any questions are we all on the same
page here
okay
uh so now so what can we say what can we
say uh about typical ranks and the
maximum rank so
one observation is that
in fact so how are typical ranks related
to the generic rank over c
so in fact it's
fairly easy to show
the following
so it happens that the
minimal so let's call this theorem two
theorem two
minimal
typical rank
is equal to generic rank
of xc
well xc is just the complexification of
x
right so i have my real variety but if
you want it's defined by some real
equations and then i take this equation
so of the real radical ideal and i look
at what they define over c that's xc
okay and what i'm claiming is that the
minimal typical rank is the same as the
generic rank of the complexification
so now i don't want to take so make a
big deal out of this i would say that
for experts this would be a
very easily believable statement because
because you know what what's happening
here is there's some dimension count and
this dimension count should not really
see whether you're working over r or
over c meaning that um
you know if your dimension is sort of
big enough to fill the entire space over
c then it should be possible to fill it
up
over r and for example i mean this has
been shown in
several instances before so for example
friedland for some
uh for some tensor ranks and probably
you can extend the proof for you know
any tensor rank but but i have not seen
it sort of stated in this generality and
the proof is also very simple like it's
a general proof very simple proof so
uh yeah so it happens that the minimal
the minimal typical rank is equal to
just the generic rank of course now we
could say well
what about the maximal rank so then can
i ask you silly question i probably said
that so the real points are the risky
dents yes that's the assumption that's
right that's that that's right so what
yeah when x is a real variety it's
variety with yeah with dense real points
that's what it is
okay
so now what can we say over r
so
essentially kind of the same statement
as over c so the maximum maximal x rank
is at most
two times
minimal
typical
excellent
okay
all right so i have stated
all of the three theorems
that i wanted
for my first part of the talk
so uh yeah i'm about to prove theorem
one or theorem three
are there uh
are there any questions
are we good
all right
so let me present uh
so in fact the most difficult thing
about theorem one and zero theorem three
is defining all of the relevant things
the proof
can be contained in one picture
uh and in fact
that's still a thousand words
that's right uh yeah well in this case i
think
if one were to rewrite this proof in
words a thousand would be very general
so let me give a proof of theorem 1 and
0 3 at the same time so if you have a
minimal typical rank or if you have the
generic rank this means that the set of
tensors of this rank contains an open
ball in the euclidean topology so here
is my open ball
of tensors of rank either generic rank
or minimal typical rank here is a point
p that i want to decompose
how am i going to decompose well let me
just draw a line through p
and this open ball
right this line is going to intersect
the open ball and infinitely many points
let me take 2
x y
and there we are i gave you the canal p
is a linear combination of x and y
right
i know that you know rank of x is
generic
or minimal typical i know that the rank
of y is generic or minimal typical so
all together i will have it most twice
right i have a decomposition of p as the
sum of two points that's it
right so this proves simultaneously
theorem one and theorem three
yeah i think yeah a thousand words would
be very generous for this
okay
um
right so now you could ask well but all
right uh is this any good
so i mean part 1.2
um
so that's my imprecise uh i mean in some
sense this sort of subsumes the question
of uh is this sharp
so
well let me first remark that
i mean if
you see somehow this
this bound uses a non-trivial quantity
which is the generic x rank or
minimal typical is equal to the generic
that's how i will get my hands on the
minimal typical anyway
so
in a way and you know this to prove what
the generic rank is sometimes could be
quite difficult actually so
if you actually want to see a bound in a
specific case for a specific x
then you know we're we're basically
piggybacking off of the work of you know
long history of work of other people or
finding what the generic rank is
so in this way i would say that it's
like i'm a standing on the
shoulders of giants
right uh but still
uh i think that this is really the best
the best sort of all-purpose
upper bound
uh
that we know and somehow in in some
cases it actually happens to be better
than the
special
upper bounds that were due you know that
were derived specifically for uh
for x
and yeah so just uh
i mean a general remark i mean what do
you expect the generic rank to be so
what do you expect this upper bound to
give what is twice generic rank well
it's something like
two times n plus one
divided by dimension x plus one
right i mean this is approximately what
the bound says
right because that's what you would
expect you just you would expect to
take your dimension of the vector space
and divide by the dimension of variety
plus one
right and then you just double it so
you know so basically you know if x is
not a curve if dimension of x is more
than one
then you get
an improvement uh i mean you get sort of
a only a constant multiple but less than
one of the trivial upper bound of n plus
one
and somehow just getting you know
getting something that's asymptotically
better that n plus one is not easy
it's not easy in many cases
so that's uh that's why it works i just
want to mention maybe uh a couple of
examples where i think this bound is uh
even though its general purpose is
really
the best known bound certainly the best
known asymptotically
so
uh yeah so example so
a couple of examples
so one example is symmetric tensor rank
so here outside of a
few
sort of specific cases this is so this
bound is certainly going to be
uh the best known asymptotically and
outside of a
few small cases it's actually the best
known and it improves bound by uh
ilyashiev is that right uh
i ask you so this is uh we are
buchinski's master student maybe now a
phd student
which is also an improvement of bounds
by bialinski barula and shinzo
and another example
and of course the generic rank is just
given to us by the alexander herschel
experiment so well-known quantity that
essentially
is exactly behaves like this except for
a few uh
known exceptions defective exceptions
and the other another example let me i
guess shouldn't write too low
so another example where this is
the best known bound is the tensors of a
format two by two by two by two by two
so which was already mentioned
in the previous stock
okay so here the generic rank
is
again the expected thing
and this is by a work of
and i mean so yeah this is generic so we
get twice the generic rank
uh
is our bound and i think
the best
known upper bound was something like two
to the n minus two
this is by a work of uh
sunni
samata
oh
i mean in many cases it's not really
possible uh to say that this bound is an
improvement of something because there
are actually very few bounds on the
maximum rank so in some cases this would
really be the only bound on maximum rank
so i cannot really say well you know
this we improved something because
something was not there before and
especially for real for real it's even
it seems to be harder to find bounds on
maximum real rank
uh
but this works and again you know
the reason that this works it's because
we're we're relying on some non-trivial
quantity because it's for yields two
times minimal typical x rank but then we
know that this is the same as the
generic x rank over c
and then well we need to find what it is
i mean
this is just the expected number you
need to show that this is really the
case but then you double it and you get
the upper bound
okay
um
yeah i mean is this going to do i expect
this to be sharp no uh do i mean i
generally i expect that this is
not so great but in the but in a sense
it's also not so bad because you know in
this you know in a sense if you look at
gets very okay
you know if
you look at for example whatever theorem
one or theorem three
you you know that there are you will
oversee all of the tensors
uh
with probability one have the generic
rank and here we're saying that the
maximum it was twice that
so in a way it already says it cannot be
too bad
right you cannot miss by too much
but still i would expect that you know
this is really not sharp in general so
it should be possible to do better but
not clear how
okay
so i think
this brings me to the end of part one
are there questions about part one
is there some dissatisfaction with uh
anything can you say this one second
proof just one more time and slow motion
yes okay and slow okay so i have an open
ball
okay i have an open ball
of tensors of a certain rank either
minimal typical or uh
or
generic right now i have my point p that
i want to decompose so i draw a line
through p and the open ball it's going
to intersect at an infinitely many
points but i just take two
and now so if i have these two points
and the third one is on the line this
means that p is a linear combination of
x and y and you know each one of x and y
it can be decomposed in uh you know in
this many so i just need to double it
to get the decomposition of p i mean
this gives you a decomposition right i
don't claim that it's this gives me the
composition of p and at most this many
cements that's how i know that the x
rank of p is at most that and i can do
that for any point
so um
what what if uh instead i took a line
from p
to a point of like minimal rank
well but then you need to know you see
you need two points of intersection yeah
so i take a ball around this point of
minimal rank and then i write p as some
of the point of minimal rank plus a
point maybe of maximal
but it has a point of maybe generic rank
well
okay so the problem is generic plus
minimum rank is already good enough but
no no you see okay over c there's only
one generic rank uh so well yeah so so
you know so then the answer is no the
answer is if you write if you go if you
take let's say point of rank one and you
take your point p and you draw a line
this line does not have to intersect
points of generic rank
uh-huh okay right so yeah
no
no but wait no no yeah if it doesn't
then you get something that's even
better
well there might be only points of high
run high rank i mean how do you know
do you see generic and basically you
just only have a line right generic rank
can miss the line or even things below
generic and can easily miss a line there
is no
all right otherwise you will prove that
it's at most generic rank plus one in
fact
just take a point on the tangent line
to the
yeah the
rational normal curve and there
you see you can't you can't do that
trick right
okay
any other questions comments
so let's move on to uh part two of the
talk so part two i still intended to
keep uh
elementary almost as elementary as this
uh as part one okay
so part two deals with possible typical
ranks so actually already theorem two
says what is the minimal typical rank
uh that's the just generic rank of c i
mean okay this still might not be easy
quantity to get your hands on but much
better
on the students so certainly with a long
history of uh
studying this so okay
so now what what happens with typical
ranks
so i guess my story starts with a
paper of uh
come on and a taviani
and
they looked at symmetric rank
or if you want wearing ring of
bivariate forms or if you want bivariate
tensors but i prefer the polynomial
language by various forms
answers
okay and so what did they show so they
showed that typical rank
typical rank of bivariate
form of degree d
is at most d in fact the maxwell rank is
also d
and at least
d plus 2 over 2 like this
and okay so this quantity
we can also identify as the uh
as the generic angle bivariate form
okay so that uh that's clear to show
that it's at most d is also not hard
uh so they showed this uh and they
showed that in degree five so when d is
five
you get three typical ranks three four
so okay i'm sorry and also these guys
that the top the upper bound and the
lower bound are guaranteed to be typical
so they show that this is typical they
show that this is typical and you have
to be in between you have to be in
between and when they then when the
degree is five you only have one number
in between which is four and they show
that this is also typical
okay so this means that in degree five
there is an open ball of uh forms of
symmetric rank three then there is an
open ball of forms of
symmetric rank four and there is an open
ball of forms of symmetric rank five
okay
and uh
and they conjectured
that in fact
this is always the case meaning that you
know every rank between the minimal
typical rank and the maximal typical
rank is typical so this was their
conjecture
um
okay so
uh
well this is now the next part is i
would say slightly embarrassing for me
so
because so thinking about so i thought
about this conjecture and
i was able to solve it
so this so conjecture
let me write it in words so
rank
between
minimal typical
and maximal and maximal typical
so i'm writing it in a suggestive way
is also typical
so if i mean this was conjecture just
for bivariate forms and uh
uh yeah i was able to prove it but in
fact
i guess the embarrassing part for me is
that uh
this statement
sorry yeah this statement is very
general right this has nothing to do
nothing to do with bivariate forms it
just works for x rank for rank with
respect to any variety any rank between
the minimal typical rank and the maximal
typical rank is also typical
okay so let me so this is this is
something that we realized and i was
talking with uh
alexander bernardi and giorgio tabiani
we realized that this is really
this is really the case there is nothing
special
happening for bivariate forms
okay so let me let me state the theorem
so what does the theorem say so suppose
suppose
rank
r is typical
and
rank
r plus one is not
right so basically suppose that we've
we'll find the typical rank but then the
rank one up from it is not typical so
then
if i look at this so s less than or
equal to r these are all tensors
actually yeah
i just need a little bit more space s
less than or equal to r these are all
these are all vectors sorry because it's
x-raying these are all vectors
of rank at most r okay so then if i look
at the interior of this set
it's guaranteed to have interior because
this rank is typical
rank r is typical and if i look at the
closure
this is the entirety of the space
so it says exactly what we want it says
that if you find the typical rank
and the rank above it is not typical
then
you basically have almost the entire
space
right there is no more there is no there
are no vectors left
uh for uh for higher rank to be typical
okay
why
uh well because this is because you know
okay so interior is some open set and
the closure is the whole thing so there
is no way to fit an open ball
you know for for tensors of higher rank
so which closure are you taking
euclidean topology everything here is an
euclidean topology
that's okay okay
and these are semi-algebraic sets so you
know so there is no weirdness of
behavior here
so great to understand correctly the
theorem and the convection
oh okay so the conjecture the conjecture
was for this situation i just wrote it
in the suggestive form because in fact
uh so the conjecture was to say that
you know every rank between d plus 2
over 2
ceiling and d is typical right but i can
write it generally and in fact it
happens to be true so this is what we
realized later so the conjecture was
just to prove this statement for this
specific case that's what was
conjectured
okay but now i'm saying that and and i
had to prove the theorem is true in
general for any variety exactly if it's
actually for any if you want x can be a
semi-algebraic set i don't know if it's
interesting in this generality but there
is nothing very special happening here
he's restating it to suggest the proof
stating it this way so just the proof
well yeah to suggest yet to suggest
the generalization that's right
i mean because when i proved it i had
some specific way dealing with bivariate
forms but there is nothing there is
nothing special happening here i guess
is what i'm saying this really works in
general
questions
maybe a comment just uh for reference
that in the special case when x was
given by tensor this was proven
independently by friedland exactly the
the
reformulation of the conjecture
i see yeah
so clean aside if you take like the most
basic example two by two by two tenses
over reals so you know that that's two
typical rank right yeah two and three so
if you take the interior of s if r
equals two uh yes uh yeah so it's less
than oh yeah so okay so if there are two
ranks two and three yes right so what
i'm saying is that if you take r is
equal to three then i will take all of
the tensors of rank at most three
but you take r equals two right if i
take r equals two then rank three still
then it doesn't satisfy the hypothesis
right because it has to be a rank r is
typical but rank r plus y is not
uh other questions
comments so yeah i
i'm brave enough to actually
think that i can even present the proof
of this
because it's very easy yeah the
semi-algebraics that could the case
could be very interesting if you go to
non-negative rank type situation so
there should be a correspondence now
with the statement that's right i mean
if i show you i will show you the proof
and the proof does not depend on any way
of having a ver underlying variety
yeah
okay
so right so let me proceed let me show
you the proof
so how does one prove something like
this
uh
i guess the answer is very quickly but
not uh but not with one picture
sadly okay so i'm going to need the
lemma which i'm not going to prove which
is deals with structure of semi
algebraic set
so
so if s is a semi algebraic set then i
want i will claim the following that the
interior
of the closure of s is contained in the
the closure
of the interior os
so let me just say this is something
that's somewhat special to some
algebraics let's imagine you take the
set of all rational points
you know in rn
then this will not be true because the
interior of the closure is going to be
the whole thing but the closure of the
interior is going to be nothing
right so i am using something special
about some algebraic sense but not very
special right it just says that you know
you cannot have something that is
terrible from this point of view like
you
okay
all right
so now so this is this i'm not going to
prove
this i'm just going to assume
but now let's uh
let's try to do the proof
so let's look
at the interior of s so let's look at
the interior of the set of all vectors
of rank at most r plus one
okay so i claim that this thing
better be contained
in
the closures i will always forget less
than or equal to
in the closure of the set of vectors
of rank at most r
so basically what am i saying if i look
at the interior of things of rank at
most r plus one i better be able to
approach them by vectors of rank at most
r and why is that is because r plus one
is not typical
you know basically if i find the point p
that isn't here but it's not
approachable so it has rank at most r
plus one but in fact because it's not
approachable by things of rank at most r
it's actually has rank exactly r plus
one
right and then i can also find an open
ball
around it right what does it mean that
it's not in the closure there is an open
ball then i will have that r plus one is
a typical rank right this is just right
this is actually proof that r plus one
is typical it's a certificate
right
so okay so then this is true so the
interior of uh
set of vectors of rank at most r plus
one is contained in closure of vectors
of rank at most star
but this means that i can also take the
interior
because this is an open set so it better
be contained in an open subset of this
so i can take the interior and now
i can make the switch right the switch
that's guaranteed to me by dilemma
because these are some algebraic sets so
the interior of s you know vectors of
rake at most are plus one
uh is contained
in the closure
of the interior
of vectors
of rank at most star
and you know now i should also be able
to take a closure here because it's
contained in a closed set so finally the
interior the closure of the interior
of things of rain car plus one
is contained in the closure of the
interior
of
things of rank at most are so what okay
so
you might think that let me say in words
what the statement is really saying
right so that it doesn't look like i'm
just manipulating symbols on the board
here
so what am i really saying i'm saying
that if i take a point so let me just
say let
that a is going to be the this this guy
the closure of the interior of things of
rank at most are what am i really saying
i'm saying take a point in here
add any point
from the cone of x
somehow the set doesn't grow right
because so basically to how do i get to
things of rank r plus one i add one
point
from x
right but somehow this set doesn't grow
right the set doesn't grow how can it be
well intuitively it just means that the
only way that it could be is that if a
was the entire space the entire vector
space to start to start with right
how can it be that i take this i take
the set and i add a new point from x
and it doesn't grow okay so let me now
let's make this intuition precise
so let's make this intuition precise
without dropping the eraser
okay so let me take a point
p and a
so it's a closure of things uh of the
interior of things of rank at most stars
so this means that there exists pi
in the interior
of a
pi going to p
okay and now imagine that i take p plus
x
where x is in the cone
so what's going to happen well i will
have p i plus x go to p
plus x
and the thing is that p i plus x well
they're certainly in the interior
of
tensors of rank sort of vectors of rank
at most are plus one
and so so what does this mean so these
guys are in here they converge to p plus
x so therefore
p plus x
is in the closure
and this
we just showed this contained the name
so basically what did i show i said that
i take p and a and i add any point
from accept to it and i still have that
p plus x
is an a
right so basically i take a point in a i
add any point from the cone i still stay
in a this can only happen if a is the
entire space why is that because i can
keep adding points right so it means
that if i know that p plus x is an a
this means by induction
p
plus the sum of any number
of x i
are also in a
but now you know basically if i take for
example k to be equal to n plus one then
i just have the whole space
right because i can basically i can just
keep adding points from the cone but if
i take dimension many points from the
corner i already have everything right
and this keeps staying in a so a is the
whole thing
okay
and that's uh
that's that's the proof
is uh
almost nothing happening here almost
okay
questions
about this
yeah does it happen often that the
maximum rank is also typical yeah so
this is okay so yeah let me move on to
my finishing remarks which uh yeah
should finish the talk so
uh so some open questions uh yeah so
it's not true it's not always true
although the problem is that somehow i
mean we just understand maximal rank so
poorly and maximal typical rank also
very poorly so it's hard to say you know
how often do things happen but for
example for ternary cubics it is known
that the maximal rank is five but it is
not typical
so it can happen that the maximum rank
is not typical i don't know if i can
make a statement that you know should be
minimal should the maximum rank be
usually not typical so for example for
bivariate forms maximal rank is typical
but should it be often
uh that's not clear so again maybe
question one and you know what is the
relationship can we say can we say
something
maybe the maximal typical rank is not
too different from maximum rank even if
they're not not exactly the same
between
maximal typical rank
and maximal rank
okay so and really uh a baffling
question to me is the following so that
we realized when we were working on the
paper with zach so
you would think that the maximum rank
over r should be at least as big as the
maximum rank over c
but this is not clear i mean of course
if you take a real if you take a real
vector and you try to decompose it as a
sum of real points this is strictly more
difficult than if you allow yourself
some complex points right but it is not
clear that the point of maximal rank has
to be real right maybe there are complex
points that have maximal rank
and they have you know then they have
nothing to do with the real points so
uh is it true is
max
rank sub r
uh at least
max
rank
sub c
or what can be said so i uh in
in tensor examples i don't know of any
instance when these two things are not
equal
right you know but you know maybe i i
have not thought about it in generality
of x-rank maybe you know maybe there is
some
choice of strange varieties x where this
is would be obvious that this one is
that the real one is strictly bigger
than the complex one but for you know
somewhat natural varieties of tensors i
don't know a single example where we
know that the real rank
is bigger than uh is bigger than complex
rank
and then
finally let me add and with the
open the
final question so let me sort of make uh
this interpretation of the theorem
theorems well theorem one i guess so
what is theorem one saying it is you can
also think about it as saying something
about border rank and rank
right because if you have a vector of
generic rank it's the same as saying
that its border rank is as large as
possible
right so basically theorem one says
theorem one says that
if border rank is large
by large i mean as larry is the largest
possible
is the largest possible
then
true rank
is not much bigger
uh well it's at most twice as big but i
just want to say it in uh
in a suggestive way
right so if border rank is large then
the actual rank can be at most twice as
big
right but what can be said when the
border rank is small
i mean you cannot get a constant bound
but
perhaps you can have something a
reasonably nice statement you know and
so for example jm earlier uh this
semester asked me a question that can be
exactly formulated like this you can
talk to him for example for some or evil
to me i also know the question for some
exact formulations
uh but basically you can sort of ask
what is the relationship between border
rank and rank can we say can we have
some reasonably nice bounds
on on true rank given bordering because
in case border rank is large in fact
true rank is not so terrible so maybe
there is some hope for having reasonable
statements
um okay so i think i actually like a
couple of minutes over time so thank you
for your attention
questions
yeah so the thing is uh
uh you know one of the open questions
about uh typical ranks for tensors not
symmetric tenses is that whether there
can be more than two values that occurs
as uh typical right so all the known
examples involve like three four but
never like three four five is that uh is
that really true um jojo
we
nobody knows nobody very nice question
that should be answered yeah oh you mean
that if you feel so for symmetric uh for
symmetric guys we will i mean basically
it's i mean we know how i mean well
already by the area guys you can have as
many as you want that's right i see but
you're saying that if you look at the
variety yeah the second already it's not
actually known that the uh
that there are more than two uh i see so
it's just a matter of finding uh well
it's a matter of proving a good example
right that's not finding a good example
finding is probably easy proving might
be uh proving my behavior okay i
actually i was not aware that this was
uh that this was sort of still unsettled
but yeah so that's something i can think
of i mean i invite everybody to think
about it in fact i mean basically i
guess one thing that i want to just very
quickly say i mean there is a lot of
open stuff i mean
you know the development of math is not
linear people you know go in certain
directions there are a lot of open so
there are a lot of open questions
especially about rio ranch
and there are not as many tools
developed but on the other hand we are
well
many very reasonable questions are
completely open right so there is i mean
from my point of view there is a lot of
opportunity to prove interesting things
but you know maybe it was not so much
tools yet as in uh you know as when you
do things over complex numbers okay so
that's kind of a hope so that's why i
invite everybody to think about this
question
oh yeah
is true still a question
can you produce counter examples by
replacing c and r with other fields oh
okay so
i have really not thought about this so
i mean basically uh for for me i have
two fields of interest c and r
well that's what i would like to know
about
yes
if you take over finance field we're
taking symmetric metrics
symmetric tensor you can do simple
computation can show that
some of the women don't have asymmetric
decomposition
so
so our final field it's it's
it's you know everything will happen i
see okay
no but i just said this one's infinity
and this one is right so that's okay
yeah but finally
but i don't know this again
to go from finally to this one that's it
so you just want to say over some
subfield of a bigger field i mean
because
so i'm very interested in the
multiplicative version of this so
replace the notion of addition
everywhere by the notion of
multiplication so if we have a
sub-variety for example of a torus
we can have a notion of rank with
respect to multiplication
coordinate wise multiplication true
question has this come up anywhere in
your work and b do you think dilemma and
the the theorem one will be true in that
case um yeah okay so first yeah this is
something i have
not thought about at all so
everything will be given on like based
on two seconds of speculative thought
uh but so
but but still the answer is i'm not sure
yeah so i don't know so i can give an
example of
this so there is a drawing work with a
student of a gm uh career so we show
that every n by n matrix can written as
a product of
uh generically and over to topless
matrices so that's a variety in the
space of n by matrices
about the maximal rank that we do not
know so if you could maybe shed some
light there
matrix multiple that's also interesting
that's right
i meant other multiplication for both
interest okay
so uh let me uh you know the thing is
about this this last statement i've
written down so all the rank and and
true rank actually can
of course you know the thing is
it it can be as big as you well so you
you need to formulate the the you need
to formulate the correct regime so so
okay let me state a precise question i
wanted to get away with just waving my
hands but let me give you a precise
question so let me so this is what jm
asked me so
uh if you take a symmetric tensor in n
variables of degree n
okay so it's n variables of degree and
symmetric tensor
symmetry so form let's say homogeneous
polynomial
uh
it cannot be true so now you look at
this asymptotically as n grows is it
possible
that
the uh
that the true rank is exponentially
bigger
than the border rank so you need to
formulate the larger you need to
formulate the correct regime to make
this question i mean of course you can
make it as big number as you want but
that would sort of not make it
exponentially bigger because in some
parameters things just yeah so here
they i mean the idea is that the
dimension of the whole space of uh forms
and end variables of degree n grows
exponentially in n
so now you know so now you cannot really
uh
so
yeah so obvious things are out because
the the typical or the generic rank is
exponential and so on so you cannot
really do too much with that
right so now the question is is it true
that if is it possible that the true
rank is exponentially larger than
bordering this is a this is a precise
instance of this question right so just
to state the question a little bit more
precisely you assume that the border
rank is growing like a polynomial in n
and is the true rank
can the true rank grow exponentially
yeah it's financially not but it's the
same almost the same as exponentially in
the border rank but okay super
polynomial
yeah yeah
you assume that but you assume the
border rank is small enough that it's
all i don't know yeah so the border
right that's right so the border rank is
small is it true that the true rank is
also small meaning not exponential or
polynomial yeah and then as
yeah well the thing is that
you of course you know all your results
were about real complex right does it
work for instance uh tropical uh samurai
for example um
the typical rank and maximal right
that's the one that's thinking about
the relation between typical right so i
mean so something should transfer some
things maybe not i mean here i'm using
properties of semi algebraic sets that
you have to be quite careful so i don't
uh yeah i mean i cannot immediately say
one way or the other what's going what's
going to happen but i mean my feeling is
that some phenomena should be general
right some phenomena should be general
are they sufficiently general to
transfer that i'm not sure but probably
something is general enough here
okay so let's tank right yeah